هذه العائله هي من عائله النجله كانت من
النازحين الذين جاؤوا من مدينه غزه الى
وسط القطاع هربا من القصف والغارات
الاسرائيليه الكثيفه على مدينه غزه ولكن
من هنا في وسط القطاع كانت الامور ايضا
غارات اسرائيليه وقصف اسرائيلي عنيف جدا
في منطقه السواح هذا الامر ادى الى
استشهاد هؤلاء الاطفال وعدد اخر من
المصابين وصل هنا مستشفى شهداء الاقصى
بالاضافه الى مستشفى العوده في مخيم
النصيرات
شو اللي صار بالضبط اللي صار جماعه هدول
نازحين عند دار اخويا وانا بقيت معهم
بالصدفه وذوب لسه انا طالع من الدار الا
جاني الخبر انه ارجع الحق دار اخوك انقصف
هذ مش دار اخوي انقص الدار اللي جنبها
وصار الانفجار عننا وعند جران واستشهدت
اللي هي عمتي
وبن ابنها وابن ابنها الثاني مدنيين كل في
البيت كله مدنيين ما فيش حدا بنخبز للناس
احنا كلهم كمان بقنا ينفرن عننا ونخبز لهم
عند اخويا نخدم في الناس لا في لا في شو
اسمه ولا في بقولوا عنه هذا سلاح ولا في
اي حاجه ولا في اي
مطلوب بدون سابق انذار بدون سابق انذار
ولا اي
حاجه حسبنا الله اكم شهيد اكم شهيد احنا
من عننا ثلاث شهداء من عننا احنا من دار
النقله اللي هو ثلاث شهداء وجيراننا والله
ما انا عارف ايش لسه انا مش عارف النازحين
كان حوالي
100 من ضمن النازحين الذين جاؤوا من مدينه
غزه الى مخيم النصيرات في منطقه غرب
السواره حيث اغرت الطائرات الاسرائيليه
على بنايه سكنيه كانت تضم عدد كبير من
النازحين استشهد عدد من الفلسطينيين واصيب
عدد اخر جلهم من الاطفال والمدنيين الذين
كانوا يجلسون بداخل البنايه المواطنين
يتحدثون عن قصف بدون سابق انذار داخل هذه
البنايه السكنيه التي تضم عدد كبير من
النازحين الفلسطينيين الغارات الاسرائيليه
مت واصل على المحافظه الوسطى حيث مساء هذا
اليوم اغارت الطائرات الاستطلاعيه
الاسرائيليه على اهداف في دير البلح هذا
الامر ادى الى ارتقاء اثنين من الشهداء
وعدد من المصابين قبل قليل ايضا غرب منطقه
السواره في منطقه مخيم لسيرات وسط القطاع
اربعه شهداء بينهم اطفال ونساء وصلوا هنا
مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح اشرف
ابو عمره لقناه الجزيره وسط قطاع غزه